hello fellow earth lovers I'm Dan
Perrault and this is how to save answer
the earth according to the movies step
one stop global warming do what you can
to recycle and reduce those greenhouse
gases or else you might be looking at
flooding tidal waves volcanic explosions
earthquakes and let's not forget cow
moving on step 2 don't mess with nature
nature is not a toy so don't resurrect
Dino DNA don't play board games and
please don't tinker with nuclear lizards
in fact if you keep tinkering with those
giant lizards guess what you're gonna
make Bryan Cranston cry you're gonna
make him cry and you don't want to do
that come on guys he doesn't deserve
that step 3 avoid building landmarks
they may be nice to look at but
landmark's will attract every disaster
known to man you know maybe at this
point we should stop trying to repair
his dad fertility it's just gonna get
ruined again in fact maybe just don't
build cities in general if everyone
could just live in underground shelters
or space stations that might be best
step 4 protect mother earth from aliens
when in doubt it's an alien crazy ships
in the sky aliens fancy car aliens ruse
Willis biggest alien I've ever seen some
aliens may be cute some may be really
cute but they're always up to some kind
of trouble whether they want to blow up
the White House or steal your cat's
aliens are not to be trusted especially
Bruce Willis guarantee you alien the
whole time step 5 put a stop to those
super people i was doing air quotes by
the way don't know if you could hear it
aliens and super people are dangerous to
earth even when they're just fighting
each other so try to break up Batman's
versing Superman's
caps first thing Iron Man's and J Lo's
versing JS bows actually that one's kind
of fun you can let them in conclusion
there's danger just about everywhere so
to ensure your safety stay out of the
water stay out of the sky stay off the
land and do what you can to save this
earth after all if we don't we'll all
end up living like those Mad Max people
which would be kind of awesome so forget
everything I just said thank you for
watching this has been how to save and
survive the earth according to the
movies remember when I did a cow joke
earlier
[Music]
you